can you talk about how characters must
have a super objective and what happens
if this goes away yes this is one of my
favorite subjects I and I love I do a
little bit of teaching so I I come from
this you know especially from the
development world you know some of the
um for me some of the more effective
films they follow a character's main
want so by super objective for me you
know there are people who are not
structuralists I would call myself a
structuralist and I believe in a threea
structure and I believe that you that
that that structure exists for a reason
not just in film but it's transferred
into TV you know into even seasons of
Television have a threea structure if
you really break them down um and that's
for a reason um and screenplays have big
beats they have a pulse you know those
big beats are designed to be in there
for a reason and they usually got a lot
to do with the main point of view or
your main character um for me if I was
to get very technical about it by page
10 when I'm reading a script I'll know
if the script's any good and I'll know
if the person can write and it's usually
because around that point you're looking
at an inciting incident and for me what
usually the function of an inciting
incident does is it explodes the main
character or main point of VI's um
entire journey into two parts one is
what do they want
now they could want little things along
the way in each scenes or each sequence
of scenes but what's the main objective
what are they trying to do Michael
Douglas in in falling down if You' ever
seen falling Joel schar's best
film he wants to just get home you know
he gets caught in traffic has a semi
breakdown he just wants to get home
that's his main want what he needs to
understand that he can't see is that the
restraining order he his wife has
against him is still in effect he's
allowed to go home right he can't he's
not supposed to but he's like no I'm
going home so these two things pull
against each other right one of them the
main character can see that's what
they're pursuing the other one is that
need that they don't necessarily see
straight away but we do right or we are
a party to that so these two things pull
at and they explode and they fracture at
the inciting incident to me that's what
I mean by a character's super objective
what do they want most of all in your
film they can't want Justice that's
that's too generic they can't want
freedom and World Peace that's not a
want it's not dramatic enough to push
their story along what do they want to
get out of this um and so I guess that's
for me that's that's the important part
of of that of of what your question was
was the Super objective is what drives
the story
them pursuing that at every moment is
what drives the story as soon as they
stop pursuing that at any point we'll
stop watching and we'll stop
empathizing because now we you've pinned
us to this one thing that you want and
now it's gone um and so that's I Guess
That's Why Super objective is important
to me what is the main want of your
character and can this be the same in
horror as well absolutely I think any
good film has this transcends
so um it should it doesn't always happen
but um you know uh I mean in The
Exorcist who's who's our main
character it's Ellen Burston she we're
experiencing the story through her what
does she want more than anything what
does she want her little girl she wants
her little girl back as soon as she
veers from that we'll lose all care and
and we will stop watching she must
pursue that objective all the way
through the film until it becomes
impossible and our job as writers is to
set up obstacles to that all along the
way and they get worse and worse and
worse as she gets closer it gets worse
and worse and worse so that's her super
objective that's what she wants I just
want whatever's in my daughter to go I
want my daughter back to the point where
she gets exorcists in and she's got
doctors and she's got she's willing to
do whatever it takes and she never stops
pursuing that ever until the end and
we'll watch to the end because of it
doesn't matter what film it is you know
um and so you know Silence of the Lambs
you know clar styling what what does she
want she wants to be the best FBI agent
she can she's living in the shadow of
her dad you know she wants to be the
best right what she needs to understand
and she doesn't see is who she gets in
bed with could destroy that you know she
doesn't see it so those are the super
objectives ones a want ones a need me
all the films that I love have those
because for me that's why I'm with them
the whole time what if a writer is
struggling to find out what their
character wants and needs well that's
where I don't start an outline I'm a
chronic outliner I have to have an
outline I have to have my big beats in
place I have to know what is that
inciting incident what happens in that
inciting incident right what happens you
know and I use Blake Schneider's book
too which is pretty good um you know his
idea of the debate sections and the set
up and the the you know fun and game
sections and all that stuff it's helpful
to help uh you know you formulate a
definition of what Those portions of the
script are um but I think that uh for
me there is along with the outlining you
must know your character you must know
what they want and you can't start a
screenplay or a script unless you know
that so I do I do character biography
work I have a series of uh of questions
or an inter I interview my character
so as a screenwriter I'll sit down with
with my interview questions and I'll ask
them a question you know who are you
what's your name okay why what do you
want out of the
screenplay you know uh what is your main
want who's trying to stop you getting
that why why are they trying to stop you
getting it you know so I ask these
series of questions um which I do in my
classes as well it's a way of getting
out building the character first which
gets a little stanislavski but I'm from
the theater so that makes sense um but I
can't I can't ignite a character's
journey in a screenplay until I know
them and I know what they want what do
they want more than anything in this
story you know um but what don't they
see I don't ask them that um because I
need to know that as the writer but an
extensive character biography and the
ability to rewrite that for instance if
I was to break it down into writing a
screenplay over one year right I spent
N9 months on the biography and the
outline carefully rewriting and
rewriting and getting to know them and
finding new characters in the outline
that service them that help them or
hinder them right um I have to know that
character and what they want all the way
to the end and know whether they're
going to get it and why until I've
sorted all of that out I don't touch a
word on the script at all then the last
three months of the screen of the
writing the screenplay is the script
work you know where I do give myself a
little bit of leeway to discover new
things um but more than anything it's
making sure that I hit those big beats
um and if I don't why I have to go back
and rewrite the outline something's not
right but even before the outline I
really want to know the character and
out of the characters biographies come
the Big Beat
outlines so by that I mean inciting
incident Enda one midpoint end of back
two into the confrontation and the end
what happens in the end
do you find some of your students are
resistant to this they just want to get
right to it or or no I'm wrong in that
assumption not generally um you know uh
I did a workshop online not long ago
actually last year and um I did find a
couple of the students had spent a long
time in one particular Facebook
screenwriting group and had been told a
whole bunch of things and they were not
willing to move from that um uh until we
started to look at their screenplays um
and like I said read watch write and my
workshops were all read watch write
we're always watching a movie We're then
identifying the big beats of that movie
and why they work um while we're writing
our own um and I think that the
resistance comes from having heard one
thing and thinking that's all there is
even I don't Advocate that what I teach
is the only way I'm only bringing 14
years in a movie studio to the table in
development and my own writing um
because of that that's all I can bring
and an understanding of the process um
but I think that the resistance comes
from sometimes not wanting to do the
work which I know sounds strange but one
of the things I found in in grad school
and Film School was I don't know why we
lost three or four screenwriting
students that year but when people find
out that the real work starts after you
finish the first
draft it can it can be Soul destroying
because so much work goes into that
outlining and writing the script that
you know what do you mean this is only
the beginning now I've got to rewrite it
but but I'm finished it I'm going to
send it to an agent no you're not um and
I think that that can be disheartening
so wanting to get things right straight
away I find to be quite common but
that's not how I learned that's not how
I become better and better I I learned
by picking up new things and being open
to listening to new ideas um and if I
can get that into a student then more
than anything that's a win how can you
tell if a screenwriter does not know
their main
character
um usually in the first 10 pages you
know um if the dialogue is is not
developed enough or is too similar to
other characters you know or the
characters sound the
same um and you'll usually know in the
setup whether a character is developed
properly um if they don't know their
character it's not going to be developed
very well which
means we we have them doing actions
contrary to what was set up in the
beginning you I might read through to
page 20 just to see whether the inciting
incident is there and what that means to
their main point of view and whether
they know what they're doing um it's
very obvious in the beginning in that's
why I say first 10 pages that that if
you don't set up a character properly
with regards to who they are you know um
what type of person they are or or what
type of you know animal they are how
whatever you're writing um what are
their attitude to the world around them
a lot of the mistakes I see are World
building you know where are we setting
our action um uh and a lot of people
forget that we it's a visual story so
they'll go on swaths of like description
on about their character and who they
once were um so it's more about putting
us in the moment and what is your
character doing how are they revealed
through action um and dialogue the only
for me the only functions of dialogue is
to reveal character or to push the plot
forward if they're not doing one both
one or both of those you have to cut it
it's there's no function dialogue is a
secondary for me a secondary part of
screenwriting now are there very talky
Indie movies that are based around that
that are very theatrical yes um but for
me dialogue should be as spare as
possible um unless it's necessary unless
you're revealing a relationship or
revealing a character or there's a
moment where the action and the visuals
can't convey what I need it to then a
character speaks and give the rest of
that information so um I think um I
think that's that's the important part
of that first 10 pages I got to hear the
character speak and I'll know whether
you know what your character is or who
they are and what they want by page 10
on how they're speaking how they're
operating in the world um what their
world is and how you've built that do
you think the more someone knows
themselves the more they're willing to
dive into this character that they're
buing building maybe those who are cut
off from themselves in some sense their
characters are reflecting that I think
that could be specific to a story if
you're writing from your perspective or
writing about you um it's I I find it
very difficult when I'm creating a
character or writing a character not to
put pieces of myself in there you know
absolutely I don't see how you escape
that um because you are bringing your
own unique perspective on not only that
story but why you want to tell that
story so um there always Pieces of Me
and the characters that I create um and
I always find that with writers too that
I'm working with is they're generally
bringing a certain amount of experience
or their own life to a reason they want
to tell the
story uh and that's through the main
characters so um yeah I mean do you come
across writers who would like to write
characters as in order to live through
them sure
absolutely um unless you're doing things
like Top Gun or Mission impossible which
I think are just Tom Cruz I think it's
just who he is someone else is writing
that for him maybe a little risky
business a little bit of risky business
I would love to see a remake of that can
you explain the process of developing
plot through a
character yeah
um I had this argument I had this
argument with a professor of mine at AFI
who insisted that a plot didn't need
character that plot came first and then
character um
I just was never able to
find that to be true for
me from the movies that I like anyway it
all comes from character it all comes
from that the ignition of that main
point of view and what the conflict is
in that in you know with within their
world or within what they want compared
to what they need it's that Conflict for
me that drives a film forward um to
separate that from the idea of plot
trajectory I've never been able to do
that um I think that
plot comes from character can you have
one without the other no I I don't
believe they work in a symbiotic
relationship but generally even if I
think of an idea for a story and it
comes from something that's not
necessarily character-based I still have
to go and find a character or a main
point of you to help me explore that
plot somehow um because that's how we
can connect with it as human beings I
connect with other human beings in the
way they feel about something whether
it's horror or romantic comedy or
whatever it is you identify with that
Human Experience through that story or
even you know secret life of pets you
know you're still latching onto
something that's
anthropomorphic and so I think plot for
me comes from the the crises and those
characters and their worlds and the
relationships they make and the
relationships they lose and the
relationship they're trying to get and
the things they want the things they
can't have um that's that's how I that's
for me where plot comes from it doesn't
come independent of
character